a pool table is one meter by two meters
so this is one meter let me label that
so this right this distance right over
here is one meter this distance right
over here is two meters that's two
meters right over there there are six
pockets total one two three four five
six four in the corners and two of the
midpoints of each of the two meter sides
of each two or the midpoints of each 2
meter side a cue ball is placed 0.25 or
quarter meter from the north wall and a
quarter a meter away from the west wall
B so this right over here this distance
right over here so it's 1/4 1/4 meter
away from the north wall so this is 1/4
a meter and this distance right over
here is also 1/4 of a meter so that's
that distance that's that distance from
the west wall the angles formed as the
ball approaches and deflects and the
angles formed as the ball approaches and
deflects forms a mirror image of each
other so this is as we approach and then
we deflect and they're mirror images so
if we were to draw if we could imagine a
mirror if we could imagine a mirror
right over there we see we see that they
are mirror images of each other at what
distance X so then they labeled X right
over here from the southeast corner from
the southeast corner should the cue ball
hit the east wall so this is the
distance from the southeast corner so
the cue ball sinks into the pocket at
the midpoint of the south wall and I
encourage you to pause the video and
I'll give you one hint it might involve
similar triangles so let's try to work
it through so a big clue is that the
approach and the deflection that they're
going to be mirror images of each other
so if there are mirror images this angle
this angle is going to be congruent to
that angle if those two angles are
congruent then this angle which is just
that black angle which is complementary
to that black angle must be equal to
this angle each of these are going to be
90 degrees minus that black angle right
over there so you have this angle is
congruent to that angle and now we can
construct two right triangles so you can
imagine one up here this is the larger
one so this is you can kind of imagine
this is our approach right to triangle
this is our approach right triangle
right over here so the top of it is
parallel to the side of the of the pool
table and then this is our deflection
right triangle right over here our
deflection a right triangle right over
here and the whole reason why I show
that these two green angles are going to
be congruent is to show that these two
triangles are similar to each other how
do we know they're similar well if you
have two angles they both have a
90-degree angle and they both have this
green angle so that means that the third
angle must also be the same two angles
if you know two angles you know what the
third angle has to be if two angles if
two corresponding angles of two
different triangles are congruent then
the triangles are going to be similar so
this top triangle is similar to this
bottom triangle and what that helps this
is that means that the ratio of
corresponding parts of the triangle the
lengths of virtue the ratio of the
lengths of corresponding parts of those
triangles are going to be the same so
for example we've already said we've
already said that this distance let's
figure out what we know about these
triangles so that distance is X now what
is this distance right over here what is
this distance right over here going to
be well let's think about it a little
bit we know that this distance is 1/4 of
a meter we know that this entire
distance is 1 meter so this distance
right let me do this in a color you can
see this distance right over here is
going to be 3/4 of a meter and so if
this whole thing if this distance is 3/4
of a meter then this part right over
here is going to be 3/4 minus X meters
so let me write that down
3/4 minus X is this magenta is this
magenta length and what else do we know
well we definitely know the length of
this segment right over here we know
that the pockets are one meter apart so
that is one meter and we also know
we also know the length of this segment
right over here we know that this is 1
meter and that this is another 3/4 of a
meter so this is this whole distance
right over here is 1 in 3/4 meters 1 and
3/4 meters or we could write that as 7/4
meters so let me write it like this this
is 7/4 I like to write everything as an
improper fraction because I have a
feeling that I'm having to do some
ratios in a second so corresponding
parts of these triangles these two
triangles are similar so corresponding
parts are gonna have the same ratio so
for example this green segment right
over here this is the longer side that's
not the hypotenuse of this top right
triangle that's going to correspond to
the longer side that's not the
hypotenuse of this triangle the sides
that are opposite this green angle they
correspond to each other so we could say
that the ratio of 7/4 to one the ratio
of 7/4 meters to 1 meter is going to be
equal to the ratio of the sides that are
opposite the magenta angles so it's
going to be equal to 3/4 minus X the
ratio of 3/4 minus X - 2 X - X I'm just
showing that the ratio of corresponding
parts are the same so let's now just
solve for X so let's see if we multiply
both sides of this by X if we multiply
both sides by X on the left hand side we
end up with 7/4 X and on the right hand
side we just we're left with 3/4 3/4
minus X well now we can add an X to both
sides and we're gonna get so 7/4 X plus
another 4/4 X is going to give us 11
fourths X is equal to 3/4 and now to
solve for X we can just multiply both
sides times the reciprocal of its
coefficient so times 4 11 s times 4 over
11 this is going to give us that X is
equal to 3
11 of a meter so if we hit 3 of
Levin's of a meter above the southeast
corner of this wall then we should hit
this pocket right over here